again thanks everyone I'm going to talk
about this work on lightweight sub
linear arguments it's a joint work with
Scott Kermit and and you all this is a
couple of years old I mean with the pace
at which you know we're developing zero
knowledge a lot has happened since this
paper and still I mean some of these
slides are like two years old I want to
go over the construction that we have
and then towards the end I sort of I'll
try to talk about some of the extensions
of the techniques that we have used in
this work so for the first half it's
about just giving our construction of a
lightweight zero knowledge system we're
going to introduce techniques that have
come from the MPC literature or MPC also
popularly called MPC in the head this
was one of my talks from the bootcamp I
won't talk about MPC in the head you can
go look at the video if you want to see
MPC in the head but here I'll just sort
of try to give the the construction
directly so I was not here on Monday but
I'm going to assume you've all had a
great talk on you know taxonomy of zero
knowledge systems zero knowledge indeed
is a is a big party as you will allude
to and this is going to be I mean there
are many ways of classifying proof
systems you want it only for
deterministic computations or NP
interactive versus non interactive
whether you rely on a trusted setup face
or or you're transparent you care only
about soundness or in addition do you
want zero knowledge succinctness versus
non succinctness and of course there are
many flavors of succinctness that are in
literature then we want to talk about
the cryptographic assumptions that are
used
in building these things I sort of have
highlighted green are things that you
that are more desirable than the red
colored ones you want for NP you want it
to be non interactive not rely on the
trusted set up require privacy meaning
zero knowledge succinctness and not rely
on public key assumptions these are sort
of features that you desire in your
proof system there are many approaches
here in this slide again go to your
walls talk to see all the taxonomy and
you know how you can unify the different
constructions that we know of this slide
primarily sort of shows where the
combinatorial techniques have come from
and again the you can see everything
ends at 17 because I haven't updated the
the bibliography since since 17 but also
if I did do that you know it's just
going to overflow in this page the three
categories here are like things that
have come from you know the classic
probabilistically checkable proves the
gkr style proves this is sort of the
first category of constructing sub
linear arguments the second is linear
PCPs this is the one that's more popular
in in practice it's in the in the Z
cache zero knowledge system and many of
the others like the bulletproof set
cetera and the third category is
multi-party computation and this is
where the arrow sits but I'm going to
sort of say that I mean now that these
things getting unified the things that
come out of the multi-party computation
indeed is sort of an interactive version
of BCPs alright so what is the main
result just theoretically stating is
that we get sub linear zero knowledge
arguments without a trusted set up a
couple of features is that you know I'm
going to describe this protocol and a
high-level it simply is it is simple
it's concretely efficient and relies
only on symmetric key crypto in fact it
relies just on collision resistant hash
functions for the usual reasons
so at the time this was this was
published we were sort of the first to
achieve all these categories in zero
knowledge systems
it was sublinear for NP did not require
sort of complex PCB machinery yes I will
I will demonstrate and relied only on
symmetric key crypto and in it was also
something that we implemented be short
actually this is efficient concretely
efficient in practice here are some of
just some high-level concrete parameters
of our zero knowledge system roughly
speaking we can show that you know if
you want to construct a zero knowledge
proof for a circuit see the NP relation
expressed as a circuit see then our
proof length the interactive version for
40 bit security is something like square
roots see half of square roots see
kilobytes now you have to apply for yet
Sameer if you want to make it non
interactive and then you have to
instantiate ours with 80 bit security to
get 40 bit security and roughly you can
think of it as twice but you know it's
actually less than twice to get from 40
bit security to 80 bit security and a
proof system works both for circuits
that can be described as you know as a
boolean circuit with a and X or not
gates or arithmetic circuits over some
finite field with addition and
multiplication kids and you know when I
say the size of see it's basically the
number of gates in your in your circuit
specifically actually it's the number of
you can think of it as the number of and
gates if it's boolean or number of
multiplication gates in case of finite
fields another feature of our proof
system that actually yields us very good
proven times like the prover time of our
proof system is it's pretty it's pretty
good actually even till recent works it
seems to be quite competitive
in the past two years and roughly
speaking the thing is that the number of
fast Fourier transforms which are
employed in most zero-knowledge systems
we need to apply many many fast Fourier
transforms of a smaller size rather than
one fast Fourier transform of the size
of the circuit which is typical in other
implementation and you know this has
space as well as time implications when
you concretely like implement the zero
knowledge system so what I'm going to do
next is sort of give you a proof
schematic of how our proof system works
okay so this is a circuit imagine this
is the NP relation which takes as input
the witness W and you know outputs yes
or no so what do we do in the proof
system the prover you know feeds in the
wires the different colors depicting
different values evaluates the circuit
and then takes these wire values and
it's going to arrange it in a matrix now
there is some method to the madness and
moving from the wire values there to
over here but imagine that all these
wire values are going to occupy some
place in this in this matrix and each of
them is going to occur a constant number
of times it depends on whether it's a
boolean circuit order it metric circuit
the number of times we have to repeat
matters but it's you know either 2 or 3
and there is some flexibility in our 0
knowledge system in in this part where
you can decide on what should be how fat
or how thin your matrix should be with
the only constraint being that you would
be able to put all the wire values in
your in your matrix in other words a
times B must be 3 times the number of
wires in your circuit because each wire
value occurs three times you want to you
can arrange you can choose a and B to to
satisfy this this constraint and as you
will see the optimum way of doing this
would would end up with a and B
ruffly being square root C and this is
sum this is why our proof complexity is
also the the proof length is
square root see so this is the
constraint a times B is x times number
of gates the the boolean setting
requires X equals 2 where we count the
number of gates to include both and an
XOR but you can also think of it you can
also move to the arithmetic setting for
GF 2 and you know take 3 and count the
number of multiplication gates both are
you know you can choose which one gives
you better parameters but the takeaway
is that you have to repeat it two or
three times in this matrix and you need
to arrange it in some specific order
that I want to talk about but this is
the first step that the prover takes
next the proven is going to take this
matrix and actually going to encode each
row of this matrix using a code and for
people familiar with crypto what we are
doing is actually using secret sharing
to secret share each of the rows of this
of this matrix using what's called a
pack secret sharing and I'll tell a
little bit about this later but for
those not familiar with pack secret
sharing it's like a reed-solomon
encoding of each row of this of this
matrix and another way of thinking of it
is that this is also sort of an
interleaved reed-solomon code because
you're just taking a direct sum of the
codes in this matrix now this encoding
we can ask we should ask about what is
the expansion it's going to be roughly
again a constant and if you ask what
this constant is it's something like 4
ok so from B it becomes 4 times B the
number of rows of course does not change
so now here is that proof system at
least the schematics so the prover first
builds this matrix arranges the wire
values encodes them and then the prover
is going to look at this encoded matrix
think of it column by column put it in
the leaves of a Merkel tree and submit
the route to the verifier so it builds a
Merkel tree where you know in the leaves
sit these columns you build the Merkel
tree give that as the
the first message the verifier now is
going to do a bunch of challenge
response yes yes and we'll get to that
you are actually well I mean IOP is more
general I PCP like you just need to send
one you don't need to send multiple so
you you're compiling an IP CP which I'll
come to it you know in a bit so the
verifier is going to do a couple of
challenge responses on what's being
committed in the first round so the
verifier is going to give a bunch of I'm
going to give the finite field version
so it's going to give a bunch of random
field elements and the prover is going
to give it's sort of going to compile
the the rows of this of this encoded
matrix using this these random field
elements and compiled a row and it's
going to send that to the verifier one
of the things over here is actually you
just take a random linear combination of
the rows and that will be one of the
things that the prover sent to the
verifier this picture is not accurate
actually you send two or three rows of
information
I'm just depicting one but the amount of
information you're sending in this is
order B elements now the prover is set
has compiled these rows using some sort
of combination and given it to the
verifier the verifier is going to check
if these rows were indeed computed
correctly from the rows that were
committed in the first round so the
verifier is actually going to challenge
the prover with a bunch of column
indices it's going to pick a random
subset of columns from from this encoded
matrix and the prover is actually going
to give these values in the clear okay
along with the d commitments to show
that these columns were indeed the ones
that were part of the Merkel tree and we
all know Merkel D commitments are
efficient you need to give sort of log
and hashes to verify each column of this
this matrix and the verifier is going to
check that the information sent in the
third round is consistent on these
columns
okay and it will be the case that you
know this the the computation that
yielded these rows and the third round
our column vise operations you know it's
not like any mix of anything so each
column can be verified individually with
respect to these rules okay and the idea
being here is that the verifier is just
opening a you know a subset of these
things
now if the pruvit cheats in too many
it's going to be caught so if you cheat
only in a few and now what we're going
to do is that then it will sort of
ensure on a high level that these codes
that were submitted are are good okay
they are good in codings and also will
satisfy the the right kind of
relationships and the relationships we
care about here are remember that what
was encoded are these wire values and
you know you care if it's an addition
gate you know one is the sum of the you
know of its inputs or if it's a
multiplication gate it's a product okay
so this is sort of the high-level proof
schematic of our zero knowledge system
the proof length is you know the rows
like two or three rows that you're going
to send in the this is sort of the
dominating cost like the the the third
and the fifth message are the dominating
cost the third row is order B and the
the last message is Kappa times a it's
the number of columns that you open how
many do you have to open well if you
want to to the minus Kappa soundness
then you have to open roughly order
Kappa columns it's not entirely accurate
but you can assume for you know just to
look at what our complexity is you can
imagine this to be so this is sort of
our proof length and now you can see
that if I want to optimize a and B so
that my proof length is the shortest
it's going to be roughly order square
root C okay and the computation if you
look at what is what are the
computations that you have to do a you
have to encode a row by row and since
you do this a by B and each time you are
going to encode B elements using
reed-solomon codes which can be done
using you know FFT this is like sort of
for each row I'm going to do an FFT of
domain size order
square root see and the overall
computation is for each row I have to do
this so sort of square root c FF DS of
size square root C okay so this is where
the computation comes from and the cost
actually I mean if you think about it
there is some amount of cost also
involved in building the Merkel tree but
what's dominating is the is the FFTs all
right so this is the proof schematic now
I want to sort of give elements of what
goes into this proof what do we do you
know in these steps okay and how are we
going to verify that what the proven
gave indeed are good and codings of
right wire values okay and the way I'm
going to show it is using by by
demonstrating an IPC P okay an
interactive PCP and you see how an
interactive PCP is compiled this is how
you compile an interactive PCP so I'll
frame these tests that we are going to
do imagine that I have the prover it has
this encoded matrix and I'm going to
give you tests on this on this on this
encoded matrix that's going to give us
the necessary guarantees on what the
prover is encoding okay I'm going to
give two of these tests or but first I
just want to say a one slide about this
encoding I mean most of you probably
know already read Solomon encoding I
want to give you the the crypto
equivalent which is the plac secret
sharing interpretation of this encoding
so everyone knows shammies sharing where
you know you pick a polynomial you put a
secret in the evaluation point zero now
an extension of this secret sharing
where I can store more secrets is called
pack secret sharing and roughly the idea
is that you instead of just why stop at
storing a secret just in P of 0 you know
store more secrets in P of minus 1 P of
minus 2 now what is the consequence of
doing this the threshold for privacy and
reconstruction sort of gets affected in
standard semi sharing this is one off
right you have privacy up to T
and then if I have P plus one elements I
can reconstruct the polynomial here to
reconstruct the polynomial I need I will
I will choose a polynomial of degree T
plus L and the privacy still is up to t
but to reconstruct I need people are
self plus one this is essentially what
changes when you go to pack secret
sharing from standard and just going
back to the previous slide each row of
this is encoded using pack secret
sharing to get this this matrix now
I said use P of 0 P of minus 1 in
practice you don't do that you choose
your evaluation points that are nice for
FFT evaluations and it requires
something a little more than it's a
little more non-trivial than choosing
evaluation points because you actually
need to do multiple things you need to
interpolate on this and then you need to
evaluate on two distinct set of points
so some amount of effort is required to
make this word nicely so how big should
L be well it you can you can have L to
be whatever you want the question is
what happens to this right and you know
L is going to be my B and it's going to
affect what I send over here right so L
can you can it's a parameter you can fix
whatever you want so you first optimize
your proof length and then get L and
again I'm just saying it as though it is
simple that is you have to also it
affects the soundness computation as I
will I will show you this T plus L and
the number of how much you expand that
is you have to optimize the soundness
equation if you want to to the minus cop
or something so you determine L first
and then you come here so T and L you
determine from your soundness equation
and then you can alright so the first
thing I want to do is that the prover
was supposed to take secrets and encode
them right so this was the first step in
the in the proof system the first test
I'm going to do is to check if the
prover encoded it using the right
encoding meaning it took a bunch of
Secrets and encoded it with a t plus L
degree polynomial okay and remember
there are many many either you view it
as an interleaved reed-solomon good or
you think of it as many many rows of
encoding this may this this fat matrix
that you have and we want to prove that
each row is a good encoding meaning
there are in too many errors so to speak
in these things okay and of course there
are many this has been studied in in
literature what we are what we did is
employ one of them but give a new
analysis for for it okay and the idea
simple so I'm expressing this now no
longer have moved from the zero
knowledge to an IP CP model where the
prover takes each column of this encoded
matrix and is one symbol in my proof
okay and the goal for me is to test that
the row wise each of them are valid in
codings
okay so how does this go so after the
prove it puts the proof in the sky the
verifier is going to do a challenge
response and the verifier is going to
simply give random field elements and
the prover is going to give a random
linear combination of these rows okay
so f1 times the first row f2 times the
second row so forth and that's what the
prover is going to give and the verifier
in the pcp model you don't need to ask
the prover to open you can just go and
look in the sky you pick AI columns and
you look in the sky what these values
are and then you're going to do two
checks you're going to check that the
random linear combination that you got
from the prover has the right degree
well if everything was degree at most T
plus L then the random linear
combination also should have degree at
most T plus L and okay it should be t
plus L but you you understand the point
and you check if the the row that you
gave agreed on those points okay now
this again is sort of an idea that's
that has been there in and you know time
tested but the point is what are the
guarantees of this test and one of the
things that we did in our paper is is
analyze it and this is probably the most
technical part of the of the talk let me
just explain what what we showed okay
yes the prover is giving the polynomial
if it gives more than T plus l plus 1
coefficients you reject yeah I I'm
saying you can give the polynomial
instead of the encoding I mean again
like if it didn't then you have to
interpolate
so basically the you know in this test
what do we want to do is that if so
think of the matrix U star which is the
the matrix that the prove are you know
combining the columns of the the symbols
in the sky now you want to ask how many
columns of this have errors across the
rows each row needs to be a valid
encoding and you're going to ask how
many columns have these errors and you
want this to be small or at least you
want the verifier to reject if more a
lot of these columns have errors and
what we are able to show is that if E is
less than the distance of this code by
four then and if the the column if the
matrix had more than eCollege then the
the chardy the the prover will get away
with its proof with probability at most
this okay and the 1 minus e over N to
the T comes from you know I'm choosing
to check if things are fine and the
second part of it is sort of the the
non-trivial part of how we show that
it's a plus 1 over F okay so this I'm
just trying to explain the part is like
this sort of influences what proof
lengths we got and we were able to show
this only for e that was less than
distance by 4 and this affects how big
how much your expansion how much do you
have to expand your encoding because he
has to be at most D by 4 and you know to
make this soundness less than 2 to the
minus whatever you want it affects those
parameters and if we could improve this
this e2 much closer to D by 2 it would
be it would improve the parameters of
our proof system and reed-muller codes
we didn't analyze like I mean this
analysis worked only for
wait why it won't make it shorter
meaning I mean you have to worry about
packing I mean this is not the only
thing that we do so I mean I'm assuming
you have to pack it in a different way
[Music]
but you know soon after we actually well
you've all contacted a couple of
mathematicians and they were able to
improve this to a less than D by three
they did it independently and the second
term sort of got a little bad but it was
still it's still good enough for large
field lengths and we could improve our
concrete proof lengths for this thing
and you can also ask okay what about a
less than B by two I mean this is a good
mathematical question if you want to try
solving it it's good but for us I want
to say that it doesn't quite help us
improve the proof length beyond the
point because there's also the Merkel
tree and so forth like there are other
factors that affect our proof length and
going to e less than D by two might not
necessarily give us too much benefit all
right so this is four so this was the
first test all we did was that whatever
the prover gave we checked that it had
it had good encoding or rather the
number of errors in in each row of this
code was isolated to at most e columns
okay so now I'm going to give you
another test and here I'm only going to
give you the test on how we check
multiplication gates okay
addition gates requires another test I'm
not going to talk about it you can come
and ask me after but let me just tell
you how we are going to show that
multiplication gates were done correctly
so imagine that the prover take the
circuit think of it layer by layer and
each layer has some number of parallel
multiplication gates okay now let's say
that you know the blue and the red are
sort of the left and right wires in each
layer
and the green is the output of this
layer now what you want to check is that
the first of the first blue dot and the
second the first red dot gives the first
green okay so you want to check this
element twice if this product holds okay
and I'm going to give you an IP CP test
for checking this and the reason I
arranged this as a matrix is because I
want to do pack secret sharing row by
row I want to amortize the checking of
this multiplication gate row at a time
so you take these rows blue red and
green and you're going to encode them
using pack secret sharing okay this is
just as before and I'm going to assume
that I already did the checking the
interleaved reed-solomon code part and
now what I want to check is that the
secrets that were encoded in each of
these satisfy this multiplication
relation okay the idea is going to be
that again the verifier is going to give
a bunch of random field elements and the
prover is going to take remember that
there is a polynomial interpretation for
each of the rows of this of this matrix
it's going to compute the polynomial for
the blue times the red - green okay and
the idea here is that remember the
secrets were stored in P of 0 P of minus
1 so forth now when I do this
multiplication it would component wise
multiply the the blue and the red values
and then when I subtract it with the
green if the prover was honest the
secret should have gone to 0 okay and
then I'm doing this row by row and I can
combine them using a random linear
combination so I check all of these row
by row and element by element in this
one row okay and once again the verifier
has to check whether this was computed
correctly it's going to open a bunch of
columns and it's going to check if the
polynomial is of the right degree and if
it agreed on all these columns the only
difference is that now the degree is
twice
okay and we can show that this has good
soundness meaning that if everything was
a good code word with the errors
isolated in each column the and if the
prover cheats in these values it will be
caught with very high probability so
this way we can check all the the
multiplication gates in our in our
circuit and I sort of want to point out
that we don't care about the circuit
being wide because you know the witness
has all the wire values so you can just
take the first you to make it into
blocks of L you take the first L
multiplication gates the second L
multiplication gates and you can do it
this doesn't impose any constraint on
the circuit being wide to to do this
okay and another thing that you will see
here is that for this test to work I
need the left wire right wire and the
output wires to be aligned and only then
will this will this test work now which
means that you know if I put all the
output wires and then look at the next
layer I have to rearrange them so that
they are left right and out so this is
why I will have to repeat a wire more
than once as I said you know two or
three times I had to repeat it I'll have
to repeat it more than once and I also
need a test to check whether you know
two rows are it's a permutation of one
another
and what we do is that we just
generalize that to saying look I can
check all linear relationships between
rows so you can imagine your circuit as
a bunch of multiplications additions
multiplications additions and this
permutation and additions both can be
thought of as a linear operation from
one row to another and there is another
test that does like just like I say an I
PCP for quadratic test we have an i PCP
fault
linear equation and I'm not going to
talk about that but if you want to come
and ask me has a similar flavor to this
and it will involve the prover giving
another row okay and this is it so our
whole proof system is about first
encoding the wire values in a matrix do
the so-called degree test checking that
each of them are a valid and
check multiplication gates check
addition gates and the wire connections
and this is our entire proof system and
you have to optimize the parameters to
get to find the shortest proof that you
would need
so I explained all of this in in in the
form of an IP CP but morally speaking
all these techniques came from the MPC
literature and the viewpoint from sort
of MPC in the head is that we use MPC in
the head we we can take there is a
corresponding honest majority
multi-party computation equivalent to
our proof system that can be shown that
we compiled from that to our zero
knowledge proof system using the I cost
transformation also we had to like
optimize this and I want to say that
this we are not the first to take
something an MPC in the head approach
actually it was first done by jakka
Melly at all who considered a much more
simpler MPC protocol to get it and I
sort of want to point out that for some
say some parameter regimes using a
simpler MPC can give you much faster
provers maybe you have to but it can
give you yeah and I mean this this way
of viewing it actually I'm going to give
you some more applications of this MPC
in the head in the secure computation
literature and also tell you some of the
things that we have borrowed from here
this is an approach that has much more
versatility than the way we have Houston
this is one of the things you've all is
saying and there is some work that we
are doing we're actually it's even fine
so the verifier opens T columns now it
would be even fine if the verify have
got some leakage on the remaining
columns we can use some leakage
resilient properties of reed-solomon
codes to say that even if it got leakage
on the remaining columns we would still
get the zero knowledge of our protocol
and we haven't been able to use this to
construct zero knowledge I don't know
maybe there are there are these recent
works on accumulators which I
don't know if it might help if there is
also leakage on the remaining columns
again I'm just I've not made any thought
into this but this is a good question to
think about if I can if I can also have
leakage and the remaining columns can i
leverage this to get better proof
systems one thing I want to point out
here is that typically when you think of
MPC in the head you think of classic
like bgw protocol or so forth and the
first question you ask is like how do
you get sub linearity like you should
think of each column in this matrix as a
view of a party in an MPC in the head
protocol and the view of a party in
typical MPC protocols is actually linear
in the circuit size okay and you know we
are opening T columns each of these
columns must be linear in the circuit
size how do we get sub linearity and I
mean we saw it from a schematic point of
view we use back secret sharing that's
how we got it but from an MPC viewpoint
actually the the thing is that you can
you have good MPC protocols where the
the total communication cost is
amortized there are works which show
that you can have an MPC protocol where
the total communication across all
parties is circuit size which means per
party it becomes it's divided by the the
number of parties and we opened only
like sort of T columns from views of
this MPC protocol our contributions just
to summarize in in this aspect of it was
that we optimized this I caused
transformation to work for certain kinds
of MPC protocols and then we optimized
the underlying honest majority and PC
protocol which was sort of based on this
work of I mean damn gosh I oh six and
what I presented before was sort of from
MPC we actually from MPC in the header
from MPC you get actually an interactive
PCP and from interactive PCP you use
standard compiler to get zero knowledge
so this is another way of looking at
what we did in this work okay so this
sort of ends the Lee hero part of my
talk now I want to sort of tell you a
little bit of follow-up works that
leverage this MP
in the head and probably shamelessly
plug in some of my recent work as well
so the first word that I want to talk
about is this beautiful work of Asia at
all that show how to construct actively
secure multi-party computation protocols
by combining elements that are sort of
weaker but also in a in a modular way to
sort of get the benefits that you all
was talking about like if I can break it
into components for which I know some
efficient protocols for one or the other
then a general transformation sort of
helps me to leverage these these
benefits so on a high level again I'm
not going to define secure computation
Elaan didn't define Ram program so I'm
also going to take the liberty and not
define secure computation I sort of
going to give you a high-level here that
what we want is so this paper was about
getting active security meaning
adversaries that can arbitrarily deviate
insecure computation and against a
dishonest majority okay and the high
level thing that this this paper showed
was that you can take two protocols of
different sort of features and combine
it to get it so actually these two these
two sub protocols that we talked about
are going to have weaker security
guarantees than what we want the first
one is an active multi-party computation
but against an honest majority and the
second is a passive two-party
computation with a dishonest majority
and you can combine these two elements
to get it and these are the two pictures
sort of that I have shown over here this
is active multi-party computation with
an honest majority where you can assume
that the adversary corrupts at most one
of the clients and at most half of the
so-called servers in this in this
computation and this is dishonest
majority passive secure computation for
if you want to think about it just think
of this as gmw right I mean if I want to
securely compute something I just do you
know gate by gate I have additive secret
sharing and
to multiply I employ either oblivious
transfer or oblivious linear evaluation
gate by gate okay so these are sort of
the two elements and the idea is that
both of these we know how to do very
efficiently and combining this we could
leverage the efficiency of both of these
to get an active multi-party computation
with an honest majority with the
dishonest majority and I want to say
that we have a word that you know sort
of shows that this is actually
concretely efficient and the idea was
that we used the the MPC in the head
that we deployed for the zero knowledge
proof system we used it over here again
it requires quite a bit of work I'm just
simplifying saying that we use this but
the ideas that were employed over there
we could port the efficiency over here
and sort of the high-level taking point
of this was that we could get active
security where the total price we pay is
roughly twice a passive the one in the
second category and this is sort of I'm
going to talk about in the next few
slides a little bit but this is
something that we care about like we
know how to do passive protocols very
nicely and most of the current
approaches at least the concretely
efficient one says repeat it like many
many times do some cut and choose and
get active security and the blow-up
seems to be proportional sort of linear
in the security parameter and this sort
of you know is is showing that well if
you do this sort of combining these two
ingredients you can get an overhead that
is kind of independent of the security
parameter we can get it to be like
constant
and this work is going to appear in CCS
this year we actually implemented this
and this this approach actually beats
most of the the concrete approaches this
words I mean what we have done here is
only for arithmetic computation so it
works for large fields
well I'll do in the next five minutes is
sort of just give you a flavor of how in
just connecting this to what we saw
before and what I'm going to do is that
I'm going to take a very simple
functionality and show how to go from
passive to active okay and the simple
functionality I'm going to take is how
you do secure multiplication okay if I
have field elements if I want to do
secure multiplication I actually use
this box that's called oblivious linear
evaluation and this is a generalization
of oblivious transfer you have a
receiver that has an input X and the
sender has two field elements a B and
the goal is for the receiver to learn ax
plus B okay and a simple instantiation
of such a protocol you can use an
additive Li homomorphic encryption
encrypt X and the operations that the
sender has to do is like scalar
operations on the ciphertext you can get
it and get the answer but this only
gives you a passive implementation now
the question is how do I get an active
implementation of an oily yes yeah
exactly you need the same the same
security property viewing this over GF 2
you can show how to implement ot using
this box so how do we do passive to
active I'm going to give you an honest
majority protocol ish for this thing and
then we can throw it into the IPS
compiler to to get an actively secure
version of oblivious linear evaluation
our benefit or our strength will come
from when we want to implement many many
parallel or Alize at the same time and
in fact in most applications you can
it's enough to think of parallel or
least because you can pre-compute what I
would call like random triples or random
doubles ahead of time and then you can
use it in the computation so you do want
this this sort of a functionality where
you can evaluate many many parallel or
lease at the same time so you can
imagine the center each of them having M
parallel oily implementations I'm giving
you sort of the MPC version of this the
compilation works
using IPS so you should imagine that
Alice takes her inputs encodes it using
reed-solomon codes and/or pack secret
sharing and sends it to the server and
so does Bob and now you can think of it
each server has to locally do this ax
plus B computation on the symbols of the
code okay and the server's do that and
then give the give the answer back to
Bob okay so this is the NPC sort of
version of doing this now to make this
actively secure you need two things you
need to make sure that everyone encoded
things correctly and you need to make
sure that most of them did the
computation correctly okay this is
similar to what we saw in the lira where
we wanted to see most of the columns
we're fine and the errors were
concentrated in a few and these
relationships were good right so you can
you can do similar things over here I
say I just point out that in the MPC
version you can think of it as after
they compute the the server's you know
do a coin tossing to get random elements
and then they broadcast a random linear
combination of their values to check
that they're of the right degree this is
sort of the interleaved reed-solomon
testing that's featuring in this MPC
program and this is it and after this
you know the the server's give the
answer to Bob and Bob from c1 through CN
can reconstruct the product then you
optimize these parameters and you can
show that each of these will be
implemented when you compile it in the
IPS frame but you will compile it with
the passive implementation of oily okay
and both the sender and the receiver
will actually check if these
computations were done correctly in a
subset of these servers and this will
guarantee that most of them were done
correctly and that you know it would be
part of checking this encoding I know
I'm jumping ahead a lot but the point is
all the elements that we used in the
layer of construction for doing this can
be incorporated in this in this
framework yes so I mean first of all I
need to multiply right so I mean when I
do this encoding my degree has to be at
least twice so that's why
the number of the N must be at least
twice M
so this gives a good passive to active
oily and this we actually benchmarked in
our in our paper so I want to say this
has many features I'm not going to get
into this actually what we one thing I
just want to point out is that we can
even weekend beyond passive oily we can
even consider oil ease that are leaky
okay and because because of this leakage
resilience property of reed-solomon
codes that I told you about and by
weakening it weaker than using a passive
oily actually we have identified some
parameters where our actively secure
protocol is better than the best current
passive I mean it's just an exaggeration
a little bit but the point is that we
can get something we can get active
security directly from these leaky
versions on imperfect implementations of
oily and this is also one of the things
that you've all was saying like this
framework helps you to weaken things and
identify better implementations of this
and I sort of want to say that this is
concretely important because if we used
additively homomorphic encryption based
on lwe kind of assumptions by making the
parameters aggressive they they they
could become leaky but still we could
use it in our protocol so this is sort
of I want to just frame this in a little
more general way I want to sort of say
that we want to as a general goal to get
active security that matches the cost of
passive security now if I frame this is
the most general theoretical question
people are going to say oh I'll use
generically use techniques like zero
knowledge sub-linear zero knowledge and
so forth so just to make it a little
more the question that have practical or
concrete implementations you want to
like sort of think of it as in a hybrid
like you can frame this question saying
that look all I can give you is oil ease
now show me how to compile passive to
active and tell me what is the what is
the overhead and I sort of want to say
that this in general is if you ask for
the most general question boolean
arithmetic small number of parties large
number of parties honest majority
dishonest majority
the the most general sort of question
order s still seems to be the
state-of-the-art okay I mean we showed
it for the two party case and there are
other cases actually if you consider
large large fields or small number of
parties we can make the overhead
constant like previous work has shown
how to make this yeah s is the
statistical is a good point is the
status you think of it as 41:28 to
whatever okay it's the statistical
security as I told you often getting
active security is repeating this s
times so this is the overhead and I mean
actually this is constant in in theory
if you look in practice it is you know
15 to 30 X overhead so there are also
even the constant ones you you care
about reducing it okay and we showed it
only for the two party case and large
fields we made the constant two and here
I want to say I have some recent work
that sort of shows using this kind of
not IPS framework but a generalization
the IPS framework works only for
constant number of parties if you want
scalability so we have an extension
where we can make this constant for all
categories and I just want to be
particularly R that I'm talking only
about communication overhead and not
computation okay and you can also ask
that question can I also get computation
and this is an open problem like and
that is again some work for large finite
fields where they show how to get
constant overhead but the question still
for getting constant computational
overhead is still open so this is this
line of work now I sort of want to say
that okay
all this modularity is great I mean you
know the motivation for all of these D
the I costs MPC in the head
transformation or the IPS was to get a
modular approach of getting active
security okay and it was initially
studied from a theoretical perspective
but some of my recent works have shown
that well if you optimize these things
you are going to get something
concretely efficient and it sort of
justifies why we want to study black box
sort of constructions in weaker
primitives
okay so that's regarding first
application now I want you to forget
this and I want to tell you that we can
actually use the state-of-the-art zero
knowledge to also improve non
blackbodies constructions so I'm going
to say that well our motivation to do
these zero knowledge came from black box
and we got all these efficient things
but now actually we can show that we can
take this zero knowledge and also prove
something efficiently of non black box
stuff and here I'm going to talk about
secure two-party computation in the
interest of time I'm going to skip the
certified oblivious transfer but I sort
of going to say that here is a secure
two-party computation I mean this is in
the past decade people have been
studying using garbled circuit getting
passive to active and now we have a
recent work where all we are doing is
send one garbled circuit and prove that
this was correct and this involves non
black box it requires us to prove things
about cryptographic operations in
particular you want to prove that in a
EES was done correctly and actually we
can show that this is in the concretely
efficient regime it has some nice
features of it being non interactive I
mean the current state of the art
requires a few rounds of interaction but
we can we have a version where we can
make this non interactive by using this
zero knowledge system you can ask me
later about about this work so studying
black box also helps in sort of non
black box stuff so if I have to so I'll
tell you later so it does outperform I
mean it's hard to compare because you
can think of this as offline and online
where or as Yuval says he talks about
the silent pre-processing so here you
can think of there is sort of some
offline phase where both of them
announce something the the garble
outputs garbled circuit plus proof the
evaluator just puts the OT first message
then in the online phase I send one
message to you which is the OT response
now if you look at the online phase it's
like as efficient as any passive the
offline proof part will take again the
currency
systems make this very efficient but
that's the most computationally
intensive part and it also has nice
features that you know the the gobbler
can post the double circuit plus proof
and you can like publicly verifiable the
the evaluator doesn't have to verify it
it can be attested you know by third
parties ahead of time so these are some
nice features by just using garbled
circuit plus zero knowledge so just
coming back using this NPC in the head
we got some nice features we implemented
it again like trying to tighten these
nice black box modular transformations
from MPC literature to zero knowledge
proof there is ongoing work we want to
improve the the complexity can be
shortened the proof by using some
recursive ideas here but still keeping
the prover efficiency it seems at least
even till today the lay hero zero
knowledge system has a competitive
proven and you know we want to think of
improving this proof length without
compromising the the prover time
benefits that lee hero has and also as I
mentioned about getting active security
for multi-party computation using these
techniques and actually there are many
questions here I mean I've been talking
about the zero knowledge based on MPC
but what about other zero knowledge
systems do other IOPS help you do active
security and this is also questions that
we can think think about and at last
I'll just leave you with one quote which
you've all says is that honest majority
is useful even when there is no honest
majority thanks
[Applause]
yes because our experimentation sorry
here oh it's Spanish do you have a good
understanding of what is the SE largest
bottleneck there is it the square of T
so when you ask bottleneck I mean are
you talking about just proof length so
the the proof length and I can sort of
let me just see if I can just quickly
let me just tell you one thing like I
mean how would one improve the the the
proof length right I mean the two
competing factors are this and this okay
now what we can do is that this one we
don't really need to send the whole
thing right I mean what do you care
about the degree of this and you require
like two tests on this thing now you can
imagine
IOP applied to doing this which means I
can reduce this okay and now I can make
possibly my columns fatter okay so there
is a trade-off here in that now you can
ask why don't I just do everything like
you know with just one row right put all
the wire values and one thing and do it
sorry exactly that's my point so there
is sort of a regime to go from Lee hero
to to star core Aurora but there might
be a nice sweet spot where you have good
prover efficiency and also reduce the
the proof length
the advantage of putting things in our
route and by the temp is that your move
one of the major bottlenecks which is
space so here you could process the
check 51 of the time and you'll be able
to go much farther than you would with
at least moment having the larger 50 so
this is something that you gain that's
gotta be the largest instances in both
cases something that gives concrete
improvements is tighter understanding of
this random linear combination in pretty
much every deficient ini DCP there is
this random year combination of
resolving put words into one and we
don't have a understanding for that yet
there's some progress on that front
deep-fry work change the unit itself so
the defects on the pretty textbook what
is that you can actually change the what
you actually physically do it's not a
leader combination you can make money
without the doing something you'll get
slightly better but more generally there
is this overarching problem of how you
combine many code words into one things
like this and today's a randomized
reduction to a single retest and if I
have one minute I'll just say one more
thing of about MPC in the head over here
this gives an interactive PCP if we used
like a different form of an MPC we could
actually get a PCP
where the symbols are roughly square
root size and this might also like I
mean the MPC again it the concrete
efficiency this is something that we are
trying to to find out but in the
designated verifier case this can be
probably useful in sort of a streaming
model like you know I give you a k out
of n ot where I know I sent you the
first message now you send me the second
message where you know each of your n
elements are these symbols now if I can
process my circuit
in you know layer by layer and and
generate this I never have to store the
entire circuit in my memory so not being
an interactive PCP helps because if it's
interactive I have to remember the
entire matrix to do all these random
linear combinations but if you use
better MPC protocols one can also get
sort of the streaming where you can
generate the proofs on the fly
and give it to me why are an OD channel
so I mean this is something that again
we are exploring I can tell you a little
bit about you know over the complexity
of you can even go lower than which you
get yeah yeah yeah as I was selling that
this one like I mean it's actually an
open question so let me tell you that
Yuki you're asking about the concrete
prove our complexity over here our
complexity is like this n log n because
you're doing these FFTs now you can ask
can the prover be like linear in the
circuit size and there are recent proof
systems that does it there's a paper by
growth brought at all that shows but
that's not yet concretely efficient I
mean you can show us emphatically that
for large fields the prover is has a
constant overhead the question for
boolean is still is open like we don't
know how to get through a complexity
that applies only constant number of
boolean operations per gate of the
circuit like through where complexity is
what you're trying to do right if you
don't care about prover complexity you
can use IOP star Kuroda and make it as
short as as as possible
but if you are asking about proven
efficiency this is still an open
question
yes vacation refusing document systems
to prove the correct garbling oh yeah
circuit are you applying in that case
general purpose argument systems or
instead maybe more something was
specialized that fatigue was
particularly well when your repeated
subcomponents was in that case your yeah
so there are multiple aspects to answer
your question one is yes like I mean
you're doing many many AES evaluations
and that helps in our system because
like doing many parallel evaluations
helps because I can isolate each
instance in a column of this matrix and
things that are benefits sure but the
second thing is that I said we're doing
non black box we are proving that AES
evaluations were correct right but now
you can also I also need to prove that
my OT messages were correct which is
like public key operations and the way
we found a sweet spot is we are non
black box in a es but black box in the
OT because that helps us so I want to
say yes there is something tailor-made
for for doing it and it helps to think
of it as MPC in the head but I'm sure
that there are good questions to think
about how to get it what is the more
clean question to ask over here
let's thankful to again
[Applause]